bienvenidos a este programa especial de
fin de año sobre venezuela en los
últimos siete años la economía
venezolana ha venido en descenso una
inflación acumulada de más del 500 70%
agobia en la vida del ciudadano común
aunado a una dolarización a la cual no
todos tienen acceso según la firma
ecoanalítica 700 dólares necesitaría una
familia de cuatro integrantes para poder
cubrir los gastos de alimentación
educación servicios públicos entre otros
sin embargo el sueldo mínimo en
venezuela es menos de tres dólares y el
salario promedio de la mayoría de los
trabajadores de la clase obrera no
alcanza los 100 dólares según el centro
para la documentación y el análisis de
los trabajadores tiendas el salario
mínimo en el país apenas alcanza para
cubrir menos del 1 por ciento de la
canasta básica es este crítico panorama
la firma ecoanalítica habló de una leve
mejoría en la economía venezolana que
este 2021 ha registrado la menor
contracción en los últimos ocho años sin
embargo está leve mejoría no genera un
impacto en la mayoría de la población
94.5 por ciento de pobreza registre
según la única cifra que se conoce de la
encuestadora en kobe de condiciones de
vida para venezuela esta misma
investigación arroja que la pobreza
extrema se ubicó en 76 punto seis por
ciento y que sólo el 5 por ciento de la
población ha mejorado sus ingresos con
este panorama se hace muy difícil para
la mayoría de las familias venezolanas
como lo veremos a continuación poder
cubrir siquiera las tres comidas diarias
yo soy el blanco tiene 32 años trabaja
como secretaria en un modesto
consultorio odontológico en la populosa
parroquia de petare el barrio más grande
del país su salario equivale a dos
dólares y medio mensual según el cambio
oficial ganar dos dólares adicionales
dependerá de captar un cliente a pie de
calle hoy no tuvo suerte se irá a casa
con las manos vacías
[Música]
para poder sobrevivir en venezuela sin
importar la profesión hace falta tener
más de un empleo al salir del
consultorio yosibel hace trabajos extra
como manicurista y peluquera en su casa
oa domicilio lo que sea será bienvenido
para llevar la comida al hogar la única
manera de tener acceso a dólares es que
si voy plancho cabello o hago las uñas
que me pagan en dólares y no me pagan
cambiando mejor comida a lo sumo en un
buen mes yo si vélez alcanza a recaudar
el equivalente a 20 dólares con el
trabajo extra lo que apenas representa
un 5% de la canasta básica alimentaria
valorada en el mes de octubre en 340
dólares
a pensar por favor
la tarea más difícil será rendir el
dinero en el mercado 3 zanahorias 3
tomates 3 cebollas y unos pocos aquí es
en eso se traduce en 15 días de su
salario a veces no juego para las tres
comidas y no solamente que se desayunan
y se dan la tarde y ya la situación se
repite en la mayoría de la clase
trabajadora el señor pedro tiene cinco
años en este mismo mercado cargando y
descargando los camiones que llegan con
los alimentos no lo hace por dinero lo
hace a cambio de comida a mí me dan
pollo carne queso huevo pedro también
debe hacer trabajos adicionales para
poder cubrir una parte de la cesta
básica cuando no esté en el mercado
repara zapatos par de zapatos hoyos 5
dólares edad pero le pongo cuatro pares
semanal antes de llegar a casa yo si
vela hace una última parada la panadería
estos cuatro panes valorados en un dólar
serán hoy el almuerzo y la cena de sus
hijos javier aviar y tatiana pese a todo
el esfuerzo que hace por alimentarlos no
siempre tiene la fortuna de lograrlo
en el mes de noviembre venezuela entró
en su cuarto año consecutivo de
hiperinflación sin embargo entre las
proyecciones económicas para 2022 la
firma ecoanalítica estima un crecimiento
aunque limitado de una economía que se
ha contraído 80 por ciento la describen
como una economía estancada pero que al
menos deja de caer los expertos también
prevén que la tendencia a la reducción
del índice de inflación es algo que se
mantendrá y que incluso no alcanzará el
1000 por ciento como se tenía previsto
las proyecciones del fondo monetario
internacional también han dado un giro
para venezuela estiman que el producto
interno bruto tengo una contracción del
5% algo que podría considerarse positivo
pues las proyecciones anteriores daban
cuenta de una reducción del 10 por
ciento hoy día en venezuela sólo 7.6
millones de ciudadanos están ocupados
laboralmente otros 2.3 millones están
subempleados el resto no logra
insertarse en el mercado formal ni en el
informal es por esto que son miles las
familias como las de ellos y bell o
pedro que intentan sortear una profunda
crisis que les afecta a sus finanzas
familiares y por más que tengan dos o
tres empleos adicción es que poco o nada
tengan que ver con su profesión no
consiguen siquiera cubrir los gastos por
una buena alimentación